well diamond heights all eyes are
finally on us
never mind football i'm coming back go
whichever florida team i play for
stop hogging the spotlight damn baseball
is fun now every day you got a new
sweater swappy it's distracting edmonton
all economic david is right i couldn't
even tell you who made the nba playoffs
with our new state-of-the-art jersey
swap factory gridiron heights has ruled
the off-season
sorry you're the shortest qb we've ever
had
oh wow and the machine also writes
tearful goodbye instagram posts here
atlanta what is there to say while we
didn't win the big one
i'm honored to wear the storied
commander's black camouflage i'm gonna
kill so many birds in this thing 200 for
new jerseys and if the nfl ass i sold it
for a dollar sir we should slow it down
no one knows where baker is i thought
the stadium was your whole faker what
did i do to [ __ ] deserve this we're
never leaving the zeitgeist now give the
people more dirty swamps
derek it'll be just like college we'll
lose a bowl game together
[Applause]
this is fun at least we have um creating
valdes gatling chiefs jersey oh no
battle scaling is too long of a name
it's overloading the mainframe must make
fresh jersey swaps
hey nice to see you
look this year's big name rams wow so
clean
hello you got me
oh this is just my life forever now
isn't it sure we need to shut it down
it's too much activity keep it going for
that laugh
good night my little draft babies sleep
tight
here's what malik willis would look like
as a panther now as a steeler now as a
seahawk oh god it's out of control who
could we possibly get to spin this in a
weird way the nfl continues to be
amazing with no problems
[Music]
gridiron heights is in chaos
time for jeff fisher and the usfl to
take over
i choose you over my children grid iron
heights